انضم اليه الان من الخرطوم الدكتور عطيه
عبد الله عطيه وهو سكرتير عامل لجنه
التمهيديه لنقابه اطباء السودان المنتخبه
الدكتور عطيه اهلا وسهلا بك بدايه لو
تعطينا فكره عن اخر الارقام المتوفره
لديكم لعدد ضحايا هذه المواجهات سواء من
قتلى او من جرحى اخر تحديث لديكم
نعم شكرا جزيلا للتحديث هو اكثر من 100
شهيد حتى اللحظه وسط المدنيين من الخرطوم
وخارج الخرطوم
الاكثر خطوره هي ما تحدثنا عنه عن تكدس
جثث في الشوارع نصل اليها ولم تتوارث
الينا معلومات اكثر عنها لذلك نحن طالبنا
منذ صبيحه اليوم بفتحه او من الامس عفوا
بفتح الممرات امنه ووقف اطلاق فوري للنار
كذلك تم استهداف عدد من المستشفيات
بالاسلحه الثقيله وهما يهدد استمرار
العمليات الانسانيه والطبيه داخل هذه
المنشات كذلك ايضا سقطت شهيده طبيبه صبيحه
هذا اليوم ليكتمل العدد الى اربعه شهداء
وصل اطباء نسال الله يتقبلهم جميعا نبي
واسع رحمته وكذلك كل الشهداء السودانيين
الوضع الصحي ينبي
بخطوره وخطوره كبيره جدا ارسلنا نداء عاجل
الى مجلس الامن عقب خلال هذا اليوم عبر
نقابه اطباء السودان ونقابات الاطباء
السودانيين في سته دول حول العالم
مناشدتنا للامم المتحده بالضغط على طرفي
القتال بالوقت الفوري اللي هذه الحرب
العبثيه وكذلك نطالب ايضا
باجلاء هؤلاء الجثث وفتح الممرات للوصول
الى هذه المستشفى هل هل كل هؤلاء هل كل
هؤلاء الضحايا هم من المدنيين يعني قلت
اكثر من 100
قتيل هل هم من المدنيين ام لا بينهم
عسكريون دكتور عطيه
هل هنالك الاعداد كبيره جدا اخرى نحن
نتحدث عن
العسكريين اغلبهم موجودين في مستشفيات
عسكريه لم يتم حصرها حتى الان الذي يجب
الذي يجب معرفته ان هذه الارقام بسيطه جدا
لانه الوصول الى هذه المستشفيات صعب جدا
بالامس تحدثت
وسائل الاعلام ان هنالك امراه ذهبت الى
الموضوع في المستشفى ولكن استهدفت هي
ووالدها عليهم رحمه الله هذا الوضع يعني
الوصول الى المستشات في خطوره كبيره دكتور
عطيه هل هنالك عدد من المستشفيات خرجت عن
الخدمه وابرز احتياجاتكم لو تقول لنا ما
هي ابرز احتياجاتكم عبر قناه العربيه
كاطباء
اكبر المستشفيات التي نعول عليها الان هي
خارج الخدمه سواء بواسطه الاستهداف مستشفى
ابن سينا مستشفى ام درمان مستشفى الشعب
مستشفى
بشائر وايضا
عدد من المستشفيات الاخرى مستشفى العيون
بالامس مستشفى الاسنان بالامس كل هذه
المسلسلات
بالتاكيد هي استهدفت
وحوجتنا عاجله عاجله اولا كل الكهرباء
والماء المقطوعه من يوم
امس الاول كذلك حوجه عاجله لكل المستلزمات
الطبيه من معينات
وجراحيه ومعينات طبيه ومحاليل وريديه كذلك
نحتاج لاسعافات لاجلاء واستبدال الكوادر
الطبيه الموجوده في المستشفيات نحتاج الى
الدم العاجل نحتاج الى غذاءات لهؤلاء
المستشفى
الكوادر الطبيه والمرضى داخل المستشفيات
يحتاج الى وقود لهذه المولدات الكهربائيه
وصلنا النداءات من عدد المستشفيات حتى هم
مستعدين ان يدفعوا من حر مالهم لتسيير هذه
المستشفيات ولكن للاسف حتى محطات الوقود
مغلقه لذلك نحن نداءنا
الدولي
الا تساعدكم الا تتلقون اي مساعده من
المنظمات الامميه العامله في السودان
دكتور عطيه نعم
[موسيقى]
واحنا نطالب بهذه الممرات الامنه ليس لنا
فقط ايضا هي نطالب بحمايه اصدقاءنا
وحلفائنا من المنظمات الدوليه التي تحاول
ان تساعد الشعب السوداني دكتور عطيه شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه من الخرطوم لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات